one of the most disgusting Republican
members of the house right now is Steve
King I'm not going to go through his
full repulsive credentials for you but
they include everything from coddling
and excusing white nationalism extreme
religious hysteria even many Republican
organizations have condemned Steve King
as the disgusting racist that he is
Steve King once spoke about being upset
that white nationalist is now considered
offensive he once told Breitbart news
that he doesn't want Muslims working in
meatpacking plants because quote I don't
want people doing my pork that won't eat
it let alone hope I go to hell for
eating pork chops he equated the torture
and prisoner abuse of the Abu Ghraib
prison
to quote hazing and he subscribes to
this white genocide conspiracy theory
known as the great replacement which
we've talked about a few times now but I
won't go into detail about now so anyway
needless to say this is a horrible
horrible person he now is saying that we
should credit rape and incest for the
existence of humanity that in a sense if
it were not for rape and incest because
it apparently is very common in his mind
it is it would be destructive to
humanity and therefore maybe rape and
incest aren't that bad and thus there
should be no such exceptions for rape
and incest when you talk about abortion
law when I saw the headline part of me
didn't want to believe it even if it was
Steve King even for Steve King it
sounded a little bit too much I don't
want to speak for Steve King so here he
is yesterday in Urbandale Iowa this is
out of his own mouth
we went back through all the family
trees and just pulled those people out
that were products of rape and incest
for their beginning population of the
world left if we did that considering
all the wars and all the rape and
pillage has taken place and whatever
happened
culture after society I know I can't
certify that they're not part of the
product of that so I guess the argument
is we should not have rape and incest
exceptions for abortion bans because if
we did humanity wouldn't exist because
rape and incest have been so prominent
in the perpetuation of Homo sapiens
around the world is Steve King feeling
like with Donald Trump in the White
House he's no longer getting attention
for saying really dumb things like it is
he realizing that there's someone
actually more repugnant and
reprehensible who's getting a lot of
attention for the things he says and he
wants some of that attention back to
Trump I read a funny comment something
like Steve King is from Iowa he mostly
knows people who are the products of
rape and incest and that's why he thinks
that without rape and incest there be no
humanity I read that on the Internet but
that would be a distasteful joke to make
so I'm not gonna make it today Steve
King also suggested during the same
speech in Urbandale Iowa that there's a
plot to remove him from power and I want
to talk about that because the way Steve
King presents it there's some kind of
conspiracy or subterfuge to remove him
from his seat in the House of
Representatives I call it something else
I call it he has an opponent and there
is actually really good news the
opponent is our friend JD Schulten who
is running again against Steve King you
can support JD you can maybe vote for JD
if you live in Iowa's fourth district so
we met JD Scholten back in 2018 August
of 2018 I went to Netroots nation in New
Orleans Louisiana interviewed a few
different 2018 candidates one of them
was JD Schulten JD Shelton is actually a
political outsider with really good
ideas he's a progressive he recognizes
the horrible nature of Steve King I
tweeted with him a few weeks ago and
said hey are you running again in 2020
because it would really be great to
remove Steve King and he said at the
time he wasn't sure he has since
announced that he is running again so
we're gonna try to get JD sholden on the
show and talk to him he lost by only
10,000 votes to Steve King in 2018 this
is a
significantly read leaning district
Iowa's fourth District and JT Schulten
came within 10,000 votes just three
percentage points separating them
Steve Schulten a Steve King could lose -
Jady Schulten in 2020 I hope you'll
check out JD Shelton's campaign
contribute if that's the way you want to
activate work to get out the vote vote
in that election
if you live in Iowa's 4th district but
we'll definitely be talking about that
one more as much as we would have loved
to see Ted Cruz be removed by better or
work in 2018 I would love to see JD
Schulten remove disgusting bottom feeder
Steve King in 2020 and we're gonna do
what we can to make that happen